you talk about guns guns rights and the
proliferation of weapons in America
specifically in this book this this week
we witnessed hundreds of thousands of
people participate you know what they
call them March for our lives
led by students young people does that
give you renewed faith it does I think
the commitment of the young people to
undertake this challenge which is a
great challenge over the opposition of
most of the members of Congress and
state legislatures and so forth has the
prospect of being successful I think
about the may be growing cynicism about
government institutions you talked about
the lack of faith and institutions and
then you watch a group of young people
believe that they can change things yes
they have confidence in themselves and I
watch there's a great attention the
marches that took place all over America
as a matter of fact I think an 800
different communities or something like
that and the dedication of those young
people from Portland Florida and there's
no doubt that of our sincerity and now
and I just hope and pray that they will
be persistent in their commitment and
they'll continue to use their influence
on adults who have respawning age
already and when they reach voting age
that they all continue to to be willing
to turn out of office the people that
have object ly submitted themselves to
the domination of NRA and the NRA
basically represents the gun
manufacturers and sellers instead of
average hunters and and and people that
use guns for for their own defense so so
I think the distortion of of a Second
Amendment has been a mistake there's no
threat to the Second Amendment
amongst other young people to have good
background checks before you can buy a
weapon and you know away with the
graphics our military weapons that we
have to authorized